all right everybody tense up  haha out of this the province [ __ ]  with me Tom cameras on me now what the  [ __ ] is the line I forgot its maximum  alert melon have some got better [ __ ]  miss maximum manipulates molecular allow  her to go for Oh would you like another  one moving on the same thing that should  happen to you  psychological around Oh mother yep see a  smooth mother come walking towards you  [Music]  Wanda vision is really hurt in the  feelings  you  you do it for me feel the punch it's bad  oh sorry fer no no no Dominic not just  tonight Oh  tip 10 that didn't happen  stay here I hear people laughing people  people falling out of the bumper frames  funny every time